we literally get to put thousands of dollars in our friends pockets and they
get to put thousands of dollars in our pockets and it's freaking fun
best matter of hacking when you can just you know critical thing right
all right hackers if you're really looking to take the deep dive this year i really recommend you
check out the critical thinkers tier in the ctv discord okay this is the place where we are doing
hack alongs amas giving you exclusive content that only the inner circle has access to to boost
you as a hacker master classes um you know custom interviews with uh extended interviews with guests
that sort of thing it's a great way to support the pod and it's a great way to invest in yourself
as a hacker and it's a tax write-off for sure so give it a shot check it out ctv.show discord
we'll help you join us thanks all right my guy 2025 is in the freaking books dude yes and you're going
to be hydrating it up today right i am yeah dude i just got over like two weeks of being cold or like
can you of being cold can you hear the uh can you hear the the the like raspiness in my voice still or
know you sound great dude it sounds to me like i'm like like talking through a straw or something it's
like it's bad well unbeknownst the listener we've had to push this back at least once and brandon is
also having some christmas woes so he might hop on at some point but yeah he might not make it we'll see
brandon will hop into the episode live so we'll see how that goes dude show him your shirt check out this
critical thinking merch for those of you on youtube look at this this is the critical thinking secret santa
2025 exclusive we're going to keep it in the store till a couple days into january so if you're listening
to this episode within the first like week of it releasing you can still get it at ctv.show swag
then we're pulling it forever so if you want the critical thinking secret santa t-shirt this is the
time to get it yeah dude dude what a year i feel like between the mix of ai bug bounty taking off hack
bots this has been the craziest bug bounty year ever yeah dude you picked quite a year to go full-time bug bounty
i did yeah it worked out quite well which we'll talk about but um but yeah man what a time because
like i feel like there's so much opportunity around like building products and doing all kinds of other
crazy stuff and also not only first year bug bounty but this is the the end of the first year of me being
a co-host yeah man yeah dude what a beautiful year thank you so much for coming along on this journey with
me this year man it's like yeah ai i mean obviously like blowing up um i think dude you we're talking a
little bit on stats before the episode you freaking blew full-time bug bounty out of the water this year man
um so major congrats for that um lots of fun collabs lots of good live hacking events yeah another year
living the dream of a full-time bug bounty man dude you gotta soak it in it's so easy to say on to the
next thing yeah i was just sitting in the hot tub the other day just thinking about that like wow
i'm so blessed to have this job this job is literally the best job if i could if i could pick a job
that yeah i couldn't pick a job that's better like it just can't dude let me just remind you guys
really quickly okay like about what our job is okay first we we get in there and we have the coolest job
title ever ethical hacker like when you're like oh at a party you say yeah you know i'm in cyber
security or whatever and they're like oh what do you do and you're like oh i'm an ethical hacker
you know and they're like what you're an ethical hacker and then you get that moment of like wow
people think this job is really cool right so yes excellent job title number one right number two if
you're a full-time bug bounty hunter you have complete flexibility you can work whenever wherever you
know you don't have to do any sales constant demand oh my gosh it's like unbelievable you just show up
you do your thing you get money yeah like and sometimes there's a little bit of back and forth
on the reports or whatever but it's nothing compared to what you would face if you were actually doing
sales or client acquisition right right and this isn't the downplay people that like that like struggle
in bug bounty like we're clearly talking about people that are like able to like make a living with
it right full-time bug hunters or yeah part-time so many people it's a huge blessing like for you or for
me at least and i think for you too like doing it part-time before we even went full-time it was
like this amazing side hustle that like if you have time to do it you can do it but if you don't you don't
whereas so many other side hustles it's like you have to show up you know what i mean and with bug
bounty it's like yeah if you have time to hack you can hack and if you don't you don't yeah dude it's
just it's freaking unbelievable then then listen to this man as soon as you as soon as you do your thing
right and you hack something one you feel like the coolest person ever because you just did something you're not
supposed to do you just outsmarted these you know multi-billion oh there's brandon yo he hugged him
live just like we said yo all right hello chaps all right sorry about that it's been like a bit of a
whirlwind all all good man all good i'm just i'm just telling the people why they should be so happy with
bug bounty you know like then you know once you find the vulnerability right and you get this hit of
dopamine you're like oh my gosh i just found it you know like yeah and then you're so happy right and then
you're banging on the table right and then and then you you know you write up the report you submit it
and then you get another crazy dopamine hit whenever the bounty gets paid right you look at your phone
you see that you know report you know rewarded nothing compares to email you click the link and then boom
you know and then you're like oh my gosh yes and there's so much dopamine and like feel goodness in
this job it's like i feel like a crack addict sitting here talking about like then you can tell your wife
or your friends about the bounty if you're able to exactly you're in that situation and then you get to
tell like other buck hunters about the really cool like finding that you had as well yeah i mean do you
go to your wife and be like hey honey i made another you know like so you've got your you know silicon
valley job or whatever hey honey another twelve thousand dollars this month woohoo on my salary no
but then you get a bounty for 12 grand and you're like let's go it feels special it feels different
exactly like man what a freaking beautiful thing right okay brandon check out this shirt i know
sorry for the audio listeners we keep talking about it yeah look how good this shirt looks dude secret
santa you see this oh yeah see that i just feel so terribly unprepared i'm wearing my gym stuff
not christmas here at all dude it's all right man you showed up you showed up right and that's that's
the thing this december has been a whirlwind right like we all kind of talked about prepping for
december and being like you know trying to get critical thinking stuff squared away and like
trying to get you know all of our hacking stuff done so that we can like chill for the last like two
weeks of december or whatever then the sickness hit you know yeah yeah there's there's no preparing
for this december unfortunately no matter what you've done there's no preparation that could have fixed
it so it's one of those ones but hey ho we're all here we're recording that's all that matters exactly
exactly um anyway sorry for letting that like you know just overflow of gratitude and passion for the
bug bounty world uh people who are living in dupland are going to want to like strangle you they're
going to be like i know i'm sorry bragging about how amazing bug bounty is i've gotten six dupes in a
row and i'm going to go jump off a cliff you know like well let me just share this one thing though
let me share this and i know you guys know what i'm talking about but like i had one of the most
gutting live hacking events ever this year like i i it was a new type of scope i was like all right
i'm gonna go after this you know and and i went after it and i accomplished exactly what i wanted to
achieve i got rce on the thing right and i had like a nice attack vector and you know it was perfectly
aligned with the scope doc and it didn't pay and i made like three grand on that live hacking event or
something ridiculous like that right yeah and and um and it was gutting it was totally gutting and
and then dude and then you know what happened the next freaking day is i went and went back to my like
uh you know home program or whatever and popped like six crits and it was like amazing right so
this time i kind of got like you know the low kind of just spiked back up right but i definitely
understand living in those lows too because for a little while after that live hacking event i was like
frick i hate this you know like why can't they just why can't i just do a job where they give me money for
effort you know yeah but this is it that you were speaking just as i joined about the the high highs
right but comes with it other low lows where it's very much part of part of the game and you need to
learn to whether that like well personally or fair i know both of you are spoken to about this about when
you're going through a bit of a hump and it's not going well but then two weeks later forgotten about
is a distant memory yeah the bugs are coming back in and it's all going fine yeah i need to have the
memory of a goldfish to be a black hunter you know yeah and that's why i'm so happy you just gotta you just
gotta keep that's why i'm so happy that's funny um all right yeah jump to our questions justin got a lot
to go yeah let's get into the meat this we're gonna save till after and then uh but let's go right into
the meat so um this will be the second year in a row of doing this third year of doing a similar concept
but um uh we are kind of gonna do a personal inventory for uh our our hunting and brandon i know you got
stuck in traffic and got hit with sickness and a bunch of other things so just like try to stick
along as best you can here with this um but what i did last year was i created like this list of a
bunch of questions that will help you understand like what your year as a hacker looked like and like
do some reflection and figure out you know what you accomplished what your best moments were what
your worst moments were you know did you did you accomplish your goals how can you improve as a
hacker that sort of thing it's all sort of bundled in here we'll release this again in the hacker
notes in conjunction with this episode um but yeah the listener should the listener should post
like a reflection like this on like in the discord or on x or something it'd be pretty sweet to see
this from like you know our friends and uh you know people in the industry yeah i would love to see it
yeah so that's a great point if you can do like a long form x post or like even go in the ctbb discord
maybe we'll open a channel or something like that yeah and that says like um you know reflections or
something like that yeah that'd be really cool yeah yeah all right richard if you're if you listen to
this whole thing i know this gets crazy in december but um we would like to open that reflections channel
so check it out in the ctbb discord or post it on x or both um all right let's jump into it first
question was what moments and bugs were the most fulfilling to you as a bug hunter in 2025.
um rezo why don't you kick us off there yeah for some somehow i like copied that one down and
didn't answer it but it seems very clear to me what this one is um i think that like the the best
experience i had was definitely in tokyo um not to toot your not to toot your horn too much but
it it felt magical right like i had never roomed with a bunch of uh bug hunters because i got into
bug bunny hunting after i was already a family man with kids and stuff but like rooming with you and
lupin and kiron was just like tons of fun it felt like being in college again you know just like living
with roommates and when i was in college like i wasn't a hacker right so like living with roommates who are
all also doing the most exciting thing ever and competing in like an awesome event and then hanging
out with all of your you know all of your japanese friends was like japanese felt the same way like
just staying up late hanging out with them um and so anyways yeah shout out to them shout out to that
event that was definitely the coolest moment i would say more more like the the proud moments were you
know kind of those like high paying really impactful bugs you know one i had on amazon was just like
incredible and you know got the best best bug of the latest ipc amazon ipc those are those are the
moments that i was like you know probably the most proud of so very nice man very nice um brandon uh
what about you what is your like you know best moment or the proudest moments you can mention more
than one so i so the one that comes to mind i don't actually think i told either of you this but
it was i think it was in april in seattle for one of the smaller ipcs um i went there gave it 100 and then
towards the end of the event there was absolute magic happening like just absolute magic i won i think
i won my first was that my first award i'm pretty sure i won my first award and won numerous awards
that event and um i was on i was on a hacker's heart it's my first time in seattle i'd done like
a lot of things i didn't think were mentally possible on a target overcome overcome the overcome the
the scaries a little bit and then as a reward on the flight back i checked if i could be upgraded and i
could and i flew back business no you didn't dude nice man that feeling i mean that was like you can't
recreate that that because the the event was like this and then it finished up here and then i finished
the whole trip coming back flying business i was like this this is it i don't know what this is but
this is it and that for me was like one of those moments where it just felt good frick not we got to
you man no yeah no joke yeah i don't really care it's like it's a couple hours on the plane who cares but
we're like i'm like 5 10 you're like what six foot maybe six three oh yeah i'm 5 11 yeah you're 5 11
yeah so and then you're 6 3 brandon yeah it's a different experience you know like and like for me
now i've done it i'm not too fussed about it but it's one like the whole thing was the experience right
i was just started off full-time in bug bounty it was like my first event where i felt like i had
something to prove personally because i was fresh and bug but i really wanted to do well like personally i
really wanted to do well and then there's parts of the event where it wasn't going well and then i
powered through that it went really well i'm much better than anyone could imagine that's when i was
like you know what let's give it a go and it like it was a lot of small personal things of like new
experiences and it all just come together to make a really like personal achievement for myself beautiful
man beautiful man and and i think for me this year like there were so many amazing moments of hacking
um the tokyo event was lovely and getting in that airbnb with the boys and like getting around the
table and just like you know actually something that's near and dear to your heart right i'm sure
that feels so good yeah that was awesome and and um and then uh yeah i mean and also just like
last time i think i talked about this on the pod near there but like last live hacking event in
tokyo it was was a paypal event which was like an event that i like a a target that i was pretty
comfortable with you know and i was like all right i'm gonna really crush this and then i totally flopped
right and and wasn't even in the top 10 which almost never happens to me and and i was gutted by
that right and then um so it feels good to like come back and like take the mvh in in tokyo um the other
moments i had on here was hacking with franz and matias in sweden um just like you know working with those
guys is amazing uh you know and and then um yeah the other one was seeing the stars align on that one
new relic bug that i talked about at the end of the halloween episode like that was just one of those
moments where i'm just sitting here at my desk like almost shaking with like i cannot believe that
happened i cannot believe this worked i've got the token it's over gg you know like and and uh and so
yeah man i just like those are those are some crazy crazy memories for me this year so i mean and
and okay the next question here was like were these moments when you found the bug or when you got the
bounty or who you were working with right and i think for me um it was it was a lot of both you know
like it was largely collaboration and and um you know seeing the vulnerabilities line from a technical
perspective but i also have on here as one of my favorite moments popping a six-figure bounty
right um which was the first six-figure bounty i've ever done right so it's like it's got for me
i'm really like balanced out across the three you know main components i think of like what makes
a meaningful experience as a bug bounty hunter which is you know technical like victory uh you know
collaboration and um and you know exactly financial right like getting your bounties um so i don't know
what are your guys thoughts on like which which one is most gratifying for you i think for me like when
you ask me it's easy to like look back and like view them all together i can retrospect um yeah i think maybe
just when it popped like when yeah for me just like when the when that amazon bug popped like just being really
proud of that one i yeah i think that actually i don't know there's something really insane about
not feeling imposter syndrome and in that moment you get like the complete opposite it's like yeah
i'm a beast you know like you feel awesome you feel like you're like a football player in the stadium
like an nfl player just like screaming at the camera yeah that's the moment that i feel like is
like uh makes it all worth like worth it you know yeah yeah yeah yeah i agree it's hard for me to say
because it's been obviously we're coming up as of a week one year since i've started full-time bug
bounty and it has been such a rich learning experience going full-time um especially because i've only done
bug bounty part-time for a year before so like there's so many good parts to it that just unexpected things
that i didn't think that would happen like collabing with both of you throughout targets this year has
been great collabing with some other friends access doctor ads like all of these things and events
it has been such a rich learning experience and has like helped me grow personally as well as a hacker
yeah i don't know there's i would is it possible just to say like 2025 as a year has just been
unbelievable i guess it isn't it really has been great i just find it hard to like really nail it
down because yeah it's been it's been explosive in terms of the learning experience the personal
barriers and things i think i've overcome both technically and mentally to be able to do it full
time and yeah it's just been insane i have a similar rant to justin's rant about how awesome bug
bounty is about collaboration that i want to get to when we get to that section oh hell yeah hell yeah
i'm looking forward to that okay so um that that kind of wraps the the first two and then we're going
to jump into looking back on your 2025 bug bounty performance were you satisfied with and then we'll
go through the list right so for me number of bugs i landed at 104 uh bugs this year um and it was kind
of hard to calculate this year because it was like uh across hacker one like i used to do largely hacker one
so i'd like sum up all my hacker one ones and then like grab a couple from over here but like this year
i hacked a lot on google hacked a lot on hacker one did some bug crowd you know it was it was a little
bit more all over the place but i landed at around 104 and i'm pretty pleased with that i think that's a
good a good volume um i think last year i said i wanted to do more uh but i also said i wanted to get
more criticality and i think i did get more criticality um this year so overall landing at 104 i'm pretty
pleased with that yeah i had exactly 100 i was kind of surprised it was a round number um and i thought
it was like funny that it was so similar to yours justin um which is interesting because i think that
my average payout is probably slightly less and i had more diversified income um but if you take out
your outlier of your six-figure bug it's like i wonder if they'd be kind of similar probably um but
also i i find it more uh interesting because i think of you as more of a critical yeah like a person
who finds a higher criticality of bugs than me on average but i think that the bonuses and um and
life hacking events played into my payouts a lot like i think that my actual finding if you remove
the bonuses and life hacking events inflated bounties then i probably would have like a lower
criticality score overall um i did pull my average impact from hacker one which is obviously lifetime
and it's like 22.85 or something which i felt like pretty good about that's great yeah that's that's
a good impact what brandon i know you don't have all the stats right in front of you but do you do you
know roughly how many bugs you got yeah yeah um so i came in just over 160 across all the platforms look at
this guy look at this guy so and like i did want to spend a little bit of time speaking about this
because obviously naturally you want to go for that impact as a hunter but i found very naturally and
there's a natural byproducts of going full-time i got on the mindset of like i am reporting everything
that has a meaningful attack vector and like i don't care what it is i'm reporting it and i'm going to
argue this very in the bounty and blah blah blah it doesn't matter to me anymore this is like my living
and my lifeblood so i would say it's a byproduct of that mindset a bit more because if i was part-time
i'd definitely hold on to bugs for a lot longer and maybe even forget to report them like looking
through my notes so i have literal bugs there which i just haven't reported um like loads so this
year has definitely been a no it doesn't matter what it is get it in report it so i would say that
as a byproduct of that mindset a bit more yeah my number is not based on me trying to only report
highs and crits i have reported everything so you just put in more work than me i'm not a snob about
that and i am of the same mind as brandon i think bug hunter should report everything um you know
obviously maybe not like open redirect lows and stuff like that but in general like if you find
medium pluses and they have any kind of security impact i'm a big fan of recommending people reporting
them yeah i i just pulled my my stats here um as far as severity distribution and just assuming hacker
one is like a representative you know of all the samples probably less criticals on google i'd imagine
but um this one has my critical severity sitting at or um ratio sitting at 15 30 for highs uh 40 for
mediums 12 for lows and then three uh none um so yeah i'm pretty pleased with that i think that's i
think that's pretty solid also i just asked hi with the hacker one ai thing to generate that stat
like this that pie chart for me to look at and it like one shot at it which i'm very pleased with
i think that's pretty cool okay so so you got these stats from high because yeah so go to go to performance
on the hacker one dashboard click the little explore high insights at the top and ask for a severity
distribution pi pi graph and it'll just generate it for you i went to i went to the dashboard and then
down to performance and you can just kind of build your own and it looks like um oh i think that it does
submissions though justin not including collabs so i think well may well at least mine's showing without
collabs so if you so if you exclude collabs my ratio oh it doesn't have percentages though oh man yeah i
need to just use high like you all did nice yeah yeah i think high is pretty solid for this um i am
going to look at my lifetime uh my impact for the past 90 days is 25. my lifetime impact is at 20. so you
said your lifetime impact is at 22. yeah 22 yeah that's sick that's good but you've been you've been you've
also been hacking for when did you start hacking um it's been like five or six years yeah five years
yeah yeah i just went to my profile and changed it to all time and i have like uh yeah 22 actually 22.27
i would say my stats from the last 90 days have taken a bit of a beating from
the event we shall not we shall not speak about it went to the floor and it pains me every time i see
this stuff but um all time is 21.5 so it's okay you guys it has gone down nice yeah that's sick i wonder i
i i anticipate like i'd have to do some additional stat magic to try to figure this out but i know back in
the day when i was a recon boy i was submitting like just tons of lows and mediums well yeah and you
also did like so to my takeovers and all that if you set it to last year what's the impact
uh just on your profile on on uh oh past year oh there's past year nice that's nice 22. so yeah
similar yeah yeah okay sweet um what kind of bugs do you think are kind of fueling your hacking
wow i can tell you that my submissions is like looks like a rainbow and this very much comes down
to i spoke about on a previous uh episode but like i have this thing in my head like know your target
and like once you get a feel for the target and you sort of feel it out and have an idea i just try
and adapt to what i think will be vulnerable for the scope i'm looking at so like i'm very adaptive i'd say
to my target because i want to find bugs no matter what so i try and adapt for that as much as possible
so mine's all over the place is a short answer literally everything every type of excess csrf cash
poisoning business logic errors broken access control idor prompt injection like it's literally information
disclosure like ssrf everything my boy that that's awesome dude that's like i mean yeah that shows
how eclectic you are as a hacker right um and how how able to adjust to the target you are i think
largely for me it was a lot of idor a lot of rce a lot of business logic i get okay a lot of rc
relatively right um a lot of rc yeah you know a lot of rc um you know uh xss off bypasses privilege
escalations that sort of thing i don't know that i found a bunch of like caching bugs this year maybe
like one or two um definitely c-surf um and cspt and like you know that sort of whole flow um but i would
say largely like i mean like um the idorminator right that's been coming back on on twitter has
been saying zwing yeah zwing a lot of freaking idor bugs dude like just being thorough being deep
testing those out getting some ai assistance you know on that nowadays as well um really valuable i think
yeah for me i would say it was mostly like probably honestly 40 ai bugs and then the rest were kind of
split among idor c-surf info disclosure business logic like that sort of thing but yeah definitely a
ton of ai bugs but a lot of that is just a byproduct of what i was invited to like i think that you like
like brandon was saying it's ideal to roll with the punches and i think for me i've always been as
pragmatic as i could from a hacking perspective and so i think that you know i got a lot of brand new
invites that were ai related programs and so it's like of course i'm gonna go look at bugs on those
and so uh yeah that's how it kind of played out for me um and i think i think we're kind of supposed
to be talking about whether we were satisfied with each of these things right and so i i think it's
whether i'm satisfied with those i would say yeah i mean the year went great it's hard to be negative
about that um and i think that it is kind of crazy maybe outdoors just live forever yeah i mean i i
think so and i think they're they're i mean as a full-time hunter it makes sense right like you
clean up the idorscope and then you focus on something more like you know technically depthful
right i would i am satisfied with this overall i think for me i would like more rce and i would like
more uh ssrf and i would like more um arbitrary file write and read uh i think that those would be
pretty valuable and i think every time i've gone deeper and tried to look at like um you know some
areas where there are possibilities for that sort of thing yeah good server side spots yeah yeah i think
i just need to do that you know more often so i'm going to continue doing that and and i made
improvement on that this year and i think i will continue to make improvement on that in the future
yeah 100 i've i'm i have very mixed emotions about mine because part of me is like just
start hammering that impact like last year when i went through the incredible ssrf run like i i was
feeling good the impact was there but it wasn't my i wasn't full-time so now the mindset has completely
changed around that and what matters to me more is around it being more sustainable rather than going
after that yeah and like personally compare the start of this year to to now the like skill set
improvements i've had and the scope that i'd feel comfortable looking at and like the collabs i feel
comfortable doing i feel like it has just been such a rich experience and like you can kind of see that
a little bit from the stats and and the bug cluster have reported per quarter but i would say that there's
been like massive technical improvements as well for me this year has been insane so part of me is
like yeah you can't probably could have done better but then the other part is like relatively speaking
you done well it was your first year you've done a lot outside of bug bounty as well so i'd be grateful
for that dude you know you all shared with me the numbers for your years in in total before this this
call and i'm just blown away by y'all's like first year performance as full-time hunters holy crap you
guys like absolutely unbelievable i did do some analysis based off of like the hacker one um powered
security report thing and um all of us land in the top two percent and one of us lands in the top one
percent for hackers so guys like let just let me understand you know to the listener like these guys
are awesome at this right like we we we are all at the top of this one percent of bug bounty hunters
um and we're going to keep it that way with hosts for this podcast like if if anybody is going to be
coming on here and hosting the podcast they need to be as a prerequisite i mean at least top five percent
bug bounty hunter in my opinion um so anyway i just i just you know without
padding justin justin says that with his personality type not bragging he says that because he wants to
provide you with by far the best information and he cares deeply about making sure that we provide
that for you guys and that we are like you know people who are technically strong and so that was a
part of justin's interview process and so yeah i think that he cares so deeply about that exactly and
and i you know it's essential for for critical thinking's brand as well i believe like to understand
that you have to be doing it like and and let me just tell you it is very hard to create content and
also be in the top one percent for something right so um really good like and i've had a little bit of
practice now over the past couple years right you guys did it your first freaking year like that is
badass and i'm so proud of you guys um so really good job um thank you very much all right so going back
to the list here um what uh are you guys satisfied with the scope that you hacked on the programs that
you hacked on and the quality of your reports i i do think that it's hard to know if you're making the
right decision at any moment in time you know looking back i think it clearly worked out but you know
hindsight's 2020 i guess maybe not though because i don't really know what decisions i i made that i could
have made differently but i do always second guess myself with like man do i have a good
anchor program what would a better anchor program be what should i be hacking on because we have so
much opportunity not just from like i mean even if you'd point in any private programs there are so
many public programs and so many of them like actually do pay well like whether it's google or
meta or whatever like there's like lots of good programs out there that's a hard question to answer
about whether i'm satisfied in that regard like it's very hard to know what to be hacking on
but as far as the scope yeah i think the ai stuff was a good decision uh both getting into it initially
and then continuing to press into it and i think quality of reports just having like ai be able to
like help you throw together reports to write them much faster it's really helped me so i'm super happy
with quality super happy with scope programs is a harder is a harder answer for me yeah yeah that makes
sense brandon yeah i i would agree so i've done quite a few events this year so that has driven the scope
i've looked at to an extent um what i would say is i would probably like to have one more program on
rotation that i regularly go back and look at that i'm in tune with i know roughly when they do their
development i know where to find documentation like i that i'm very much in tune with i'd like one
more of those because i feel like that would be quite beneficial how many do you have i have two two
two right now i did have another one but then i sort of gone off of it so um i would like three
titles that i can rotate through um consistently and have that on so that definitely would be a bigger
goal for me next year um but other than that i would say in hindsight it was as best it could be
yeah i i want to say i have three base programs and they're actually all public so i can talk about
them all they're google epic and capital one um and feels good man i mean i think i'm basically like
zero like for me it's a kind of good kind of google but i don't really like come back to it consistently
in the way you do so i think that that should be a goal for mine is to like pick you know two
no anchor program and you earned that dude you crushed it this year man you that's pretty crazy that is
sick um yeah i think as far as quality of reports goes google has a um report quality bonus that they
give out and just being like financially incentivized to do that built some good habits for me i think
that i even found transferring to other programs um so shout out to google for like building the whole
ecosystem like encouraging hackers to write better reports in general by their report bonus and i think
that definitely um that definitely helped me this year um as an outsider who saw you do that i just
want to say to the audience because i think it's like a really good technical tip justin almost always
records a video for any high plus vulnerability and also spends way more time on pocs than i think most
people do like um i would say you know when you're doing when you're doing bug bounty like you know most
people will throw together a poc or have an okay one maybe but um on some of our reports like specifically
thinking about the google tokyo event justin put in hours on a poc to make it realistic looking and i
think it probably 5x the bounty like it was about actually to be honest it might have went from unpaid
to paid as a higher critical legitimately just because of the quality of the poc and so i think that
that is like probably a really great takeaway yeah yeah i i know the report you're talking about and and
like it was a hard call and and thank you guys for standing by me with that you know in the live
hacking event for me to spend you know three hours putting together a poc in the middle of a live
hacking event the day before you know the competition right um but it did it did work out this time and
i have in my notes here that i think like now i am addressing root cause and and suggesting fixes in
my reports which i think is good i think i still let the poc and poc video do a little bit too
much talking you know for for my report like i think i could probably explain things from like
a technical perspective in text better um yeah it's very frustrating when a tree roger comes in and
asks a question that you answer clearly in your video and you're like i should have just put it in
text yeah exactly exactly so i think if i can just get that video and you know hopefully i think i think
that is the most impactful thing right like poc or gtfo like if you can provide a good poc and a poc video
the impact and the um you know methodology should explain itself to most technical people right um but
i think because there are so many layers that go into bug bounty like triage you know uh people that
are creating the tickets you know then the devs then the security team you know it does help to
have it in text as well and just hit it from all angles yeah sweet i didn't have anything else there
brandon no i think i've always been from the reporting side okay uh anything medium is like
my 80 and then anything high increase the video the full works this is why this is why i've given it
the cvss metric this is why it affects integrity and things like that so i would say the rapport effort
does coincide with the reports severity too so that's just a bit of the meta strategy i have though
i like the explaining the cvss i've done that with programs that have like high cvss correlation
right where it's like okay they pay by the book for cvss which one of my anchor programs does
um so yeah i think that's a good call and i imagine you get a lot higher a lot less back and
forth because of that exactly what i would say and i've recently went on the pod and spoke about this
is that cvss and ai fundamentally doesn't work um it's not true for purpose so don't do that for an ai
bug because you will get screwed 10 times out of 10 every single time so for your traditional web and
mobile and things like that that's okay but not ai yeah it requires too much user interaction and yeah
and the impact is often one user right so it's tough but uh like you know like we've we've pushed
for in the past you know it's a new skill set it's a new domain you know we recommend programs like
trying to pay it well yeah i i did want to share something anecdotally about that though because
we did the episode with sassy right um which i would recommend you all go back and listen to if you
haven't i know that we do a lot of ai stuff but this is really going to be pivotal um you know in
noma security on the gemini jack thing and i i watched the episode and of course you know recorded the
episode and and it was very interesting you know to see the approach that that he went through and
made to make it zero click right where it's just the users just asking their normal workflow and then
they get pwned and then uh you know it caused and obviously people are going to go into gemini and
ask like hey you know can you summarize this for me right but i have to say for the first time
like last week i actually did that myself like i i went into gemini i said hey check my email and
create an itinerary for this trip right that i that i that i already booked all the stuff i just want
an itinerary and you thought i could have just got zero clicked yeah and then and then as i press
enter i'm like shit like that this looks like the beginning of a poc video you know like and and but
but i think that validates right that validates the attack factor that like as a user i just did that
right and you know maybe we're the most tech forward bunch but everybody's going to be doing that
in like a year you know if they're not already um so yeah exactly i feel like that needs to mature a bit
from triage side and also internal program knowledge side because i i've personally had so much friction
around like okay you are using cbss for this but that is like normal user interaction so do you set ui
required or like right where does the scope change in in this context so yeah yeah there needs to be a
new there needs to be something new there but i i agree with everything you said i firmly believe
that if you're not coming to an attacker controlled site and you're performing a an action that normal
users would do with normal use of the application then that is not ui required i think we need a blog
post for that or or something we need we need something that's a blog post about that on both scope
and ui i think scoping ui for cvs on ai bugs it'd be really nice to have like a reference doc yeah you're
the blog guy dude you got it i will yeah yeah no i'll do a post on this i like it do it i gotta stand
up for my boys yeah i think i i think um one of the interesting thing that i realized this year as well
with my honk honk talk i really enjoyed that talk and i would really recommend the listeners go check it
out um but i i hate doing talks bro like i i hate prepping slides like i hate it i procrastinate
to no end i and then cram it the last day and i i think it's so funny how i can come on here in the
pod and talk for you know an hour hour and a half every week and like give no lilies and like just like
not bother me at all right and and then like if i have to prep slides and do a talk on it like giving
the talk itself is not a problem like i love giving the talk but like prepping the slides for a talk is
like the worst so i think i i've decided i'm never going to do it again sorry i think i've decided i think
i'm never going to do it again i think i don't have to do it i think i i i have i have money i
have time i have like i have a podcast i produce content i don't have to give a talk ever again i
think you know i think you should just do a live talk basically just do a live podcast like you can
be like hey i'll get up there i'll do panels you can even tell you can even ask me questions about the
bugs that you want me to talk about you can do hosting so i think that's fine i love it i really love
radical decisions around lifestyle design and if this is something that you've decided that you
just don't love don't ever do it again i just hate it and and you know the thing is maybe i'll do a
little like recording or something like that and i'll just pay somebody to go prep the slides or whatever
oh maybe they could do the slides over top of it yeah exactly you know and and but i just realized i
hate it and and like and i don't want to spend my time doing it and looking back at this past year
the the times that i've been most stressed are when i'm doing that and i and i just like and like
literally and like you that says a lot right you freakers know my year that i've had right yeah yeah
and and probably i've had a stressful year in lots of other ways but like easily top top five
three of them are are prepping slides i don't know i don't i don't understand how the security
industry has ran off of conferences for so long because i feel the exact same way justin and it's
crazy to me that so many people will spend like weeks or months doing research weeks doing slides
and then they go to a conference and speak for to speak in front of 10 people i'm like holy crap
people like uh don't realize the amount of effort that goes into people's talks that they get no reach
i just also feel like my slides look like you know that's the other thing is like i spend a lot
of time like and maybe ai will fix this you know in the next year hopefully and i know gamma's already
doing some good stuff with this but um i also feel like i get to the end of it and i'm like wow this
looks bad you know like and and you know for me as a hacker i just like you know what actually i don't
give a shit you know like i'm just going to present it like it gets the content across it helps the
people that's the goal right it's not we're not like you know freaking giving a you know talk to
pitch people for an investment or something you know like um but yeah i think i think either i'm just
going to not do it or i'm going to have somebody else make the slides and then i'll deliver the talk and
and that'll be what it is brandon what you're giving me for this why are you giving me no no no no no i'm
not giving you any stick at all i i respect it as a friend but i'm upset because i know how much
people and the community loves the stuff you do and how much of like uh of a pillar you are because when
you do talk people listen that's why i'm a big guy but as a friend i respect it they just got to tune
into the hack alongs to keep listening to the pod right wow that's it man yeah well that's the other
thing is like i don't want to not give back to the community so i will do podcasts right you know
uh i just don't like the visual piece of it like creating the like i'm not very visually creative in
general actually i think this is like a personal we're getting really off topic here but i think
this is like a personal weakness for me is like you know i can't draw like like everything artistically
that i do is is like music right um and so like no no drawing no painting no you know even like design
right like design of like interior design or or even like right i do real estate renos right i completely
blindly trust my wife with that like i say mariah tell me what we're doing here and then she does it
she tells me and then i go make it happen right um and it looks great every time which is great you
know and she's got my back there um but i think just visually like i think that's a weakness and so
yeah i think when i'm trying to work from this area that's a weakness it stresses me out and it doesn't
get good results and so that those are the things you should kick out of your life yeah right yeah i mean
yeah i just before we move on i completely agree and when i obviously done the hacker notes ug would
like look at my templates and like look at my stuff and he's like how do you work with this it doesn't
look good and i'm like i'm not in the business of making stuff look good at all it's far beyond my
comprehension or ability so please if you want to do that do that but i'm focusing on content
i'm in the same boat as you mate i do want to gas up our man brandon here though from a talks
perspective 2025 brought him a lot of inbound and yeah and boosted his personal brand so talks can
also do wonders for things obviously justin you you have the personal brand or as brandon is building
his up right now but i think that like uh you know they can still be very powerful you know yeah brandon
used them to great um to great uh what's the word there to great effect in 2025 and i think that's really cool
cool yeah i think thank you yeah i totally agree there and i think i'm gonna miss giving talks right
like if i don't find a good solution to have somebody make slides then i i'm gonna miss giving
talks because i love giving talks giving talks is the best you know and and like especially like when
you're giving them live like i will say you know it makes sense right like maybe we should just upload
the talk to youtube and not instead of giving them in a room of 20 people but it's also pretty sick
when you're in the room with like you know all right let's call it 50 people or 100 people and you got
your mic'd up you got your slides behind you you're talking about something you're really passionate
about you're walking through the crowd you know talking to people and and like you know explaining
things and like you know transferring that energy out you know we kind of get spoiled because we get to
do that every week on the pod right but but you know being there in person i think definitely does
have a little bit of a different aspect to it yeah yeah yeah okay okay okay okay we got we got super way
off topic here but um let's let's hit these pretty quickly um okay we've got 30 minutes we're good
um are you happy with your current level of automation organization collaboration
who's starting uh let's let's start with you brandon me okay so automation um
you both probably know that i'm slowly and i'm not talking like full-scale automation i'm more
talking about workflow automation um i've upped that i went from nothing to something this year and
that for me came in the form of javascript monitoring and that's now i would consider in
quite a good spot quite a powerful spot i say i integrated and it's actually feeding me leads
which are actionable um so i'm happy on that front and i'm not an automation guy
and i've also spent a lot of time vibe coding a lot of things so if it wasn't for vibe coding i
would have nothing i will probably say that out of like i just couldn't bring myself to do it because
i know i could be hacking and making more money but vibe coding is very like it's a vibe as the name
suggests it's good it's fun it's it's frictionless almost so i'd say yes on the automation definitely
getting there the organization solely and i mean solely held together by my notes and my note
structure that is it that is probably the the only organization i have in my life um so yes i would say
better on that what and here's something i do want to talk to you to about what i found is though that
completely goes out of the window in a live event i don't know what it is i'm like i'm more frantic in a
live event and i use my i use my notepad more but not my notion more do in a live event do you guys
take notes or how yeah i i take notes ah i don't want to say almost exclusively at live hacking events
but like same kind of kind of more way way more during events for me yeah so yeah see it's different
for me i take i i take note of like the gadget or weird behavior but i don't take a lot of the context
if that makes sense so like they're very brief and nowhere near as concise as my main as my main notion
so i i've noticed in your notion stuff you you you take a lot of detailed notes like about the stack and
stuff like that too i think for me this year i'm going to be spending i'm going to be pushing a lot
of that to ai because kaido kind of shift agents like dude i was blown away like i mentioned this in
the talk but like i ran a research agent um from from kaido on a target that i is one of my core targets
and an api i'm very familiar with and it like pulled three or four insights that i did not know about
you know and correlated things and i was like oh wow that's that's very insightful actually and and um
and so i'm definitely going to be using um shift agents uh to to like do that sort of research and
note-taking in the future and then take those learnings right because it'll create learnings in
its system and just export those to notes yeah that's that's really nice i think i'm gonna explore
that a bit more reza i feel like you've always got some nice little like something i don't know
workflow wise like the fuff master class i was just taken back by how much of a noob i was and like
all these other little ai things i always consult you on in terms of workflow so i feel like you're
doing something there well the audience doesn't know that i gave you that little master class that's
funny i hopped on a meeting with brandon and like walked him through how to use ffuf the right way
so that was kind of fun but um no honestly so my answer to this is no i've not been doing enough
of it i think i did less this year than i've ever done and i'm really sad about it because i feel
like i'm the hackbot guy and i have people like jd messaging me how they're using cloud code to
he's been using cloud code to find tons of bugs and justin you know did the shift agents talk and
research and i'm like jealous of it too so you know i'm i'm uh resting in my contentment i think this is
an incredible year both you know with my young kids even though we've had a crazy year as well and then
also you know professionally but no yeah my answer to this question is i'm not happy with my automation i want
to do much more of it i think that oh i dropped i dropped my ring um i think that there's a much more
capability for people to do that now with vibe coding which i really really enjoy and so i think that i
should build more automation in that way and more hackbot automation i think that kaido and shifter
and like the best place ever to be able to find some insane bugs uh organization i've been fine on and
collaboration i have um yeah i collaborated maybe a lot in the earlier part of the year and then less in the
later part of the year and i had this light bulb moment that i wanted to mention i think i messaged justin
when it when it when it first had this light bulb moment but i think that there is a desire to you know
be personally awesome and i think that you know all hackers go through that desire you know to like
fight back imposter syndrome and to feel awesome and to like you know really pursue mbh and um i don't
know i think that the pursuit of that i basically have had like maybe let's say three or four events
over the last two years where it was like nope i'm gonna go solo i'll do some maybe some like light
collaboration with people if like it makes sense like one off my goal is to be solo and in every one
of those i left way less satisfied with the results and way i felt like i was under motivated in them
even though the whole point of doing it that way was to be more motivated and so i think that i am just
a type of person who is more energized and more motivated which i know i'm an extrovert right but i think
that i actually have seen that play out in my life so many times now that i'm going to always pursue
collaboration and i think that it is an incredible aspect of our industry and the fact that like we
literally get to put thousands of dollars in our friends pockets and they get to put thousands of
dollars in our pockets and it's freaking fun and i'm learning way more and i'm getting filled up and
enjoying it way more and that maybe that matters maybe more than we can even tangibly you know
understand because like that affects how much you want to do it that night and how much you want to
do it the next day and how much you know you're talking about it with your friends the next week
right and i think that collaboration allows you to talk about leads which are really interesting and
fun to talk about and when you're solo and you don't get to share those like those little pieces of
quirky behavior with others you know maybe you do once the dupe period's over right or maybe you do
the next week or maybe you do at some point but i think like sharing those as they occur
kind of can create more hype and more fuel like to the fire that makes it more exciting and more fun
and it definitely ends up in way more bugs for me personally i know that like justin you know is
often more of a solo flyer and does better that way too but i think that for me like i've just decided
i'm going to stop attempting to go into events solo unless for some reason you know like i pre-hacked
and i found a bunch of bugs and i think like this is the one to make the run for mvh on or something
um i think that for me personally i just like had that light bulb moment in the same way justin
doesn't want to talk anymore i don't want to do solo events anymore yeah no that's very good man
brandon i i'm i'm curious are you an introvert or an extrovert
mate i would you don't know this very much i don't know i think it depends on who you ask i'm very i have
some funky wiring i would say so i'm not i don't know how to answer that this is usually the best way to
answer it when you leave a social gathering are you like oh man i need to rest i'm a little worn out
or do you get home and your mind's buzzing like holy crap i wish i could have hung out for another
three hours with those people no no no rest okay yeah okay probably so maybe a little little bit on
on the line but definitely on the introvert side i think it's very rare i'm squarely in the introvert
category um but like i think it's pretty rare to see like a solid like solid extrovert you know
do well in in this industry because it's it is kind of lonely you know yeah so uh you definitely got
something special going there rezo uh yeah thanks i mean i do think that there's like a power in that
so if there's anybody out there who feels extroverted and feels like they're a little
they're struggling like i just feel i have used it to like i just have like a mapping of like hey these
people are good at these things in my head and i just message friends like even when i got started
i've noticed you know fav he's gonna love getting shout out on this fav up and coming young hacker
and he is so networky right he finds a cool lead and he messaged it to all of us right he finds a
cool bug he tells everyone about it and i think that this is actually a good way to use extroversion
as a way to kind of like level up because you get feedback and you get network you get connections
like i messaged him like i was hacking microsoft whenever they dropped that new thing where
they're paying for all criticals and i like i fuzz them overnight and like i send him the leads right
because i know he hacks on microsoft and like he's already messaging me and so it just kind of like
pays off to be like talking to people all the time totally yeah no i do agree yeah after 30 seconds of
reflection i'd probably serve for more into the introvert bucket like it's being it takes a ungodly amount of
energy from to force myself to post on like social and things actually talking to people like you guys
and networking is fine but like i need to be compartmentalized and have like my me time for
a day when there is no talking and nothing going on rather than just me in the zone i need that but
dude that's that's the ticket right there though because like if you're an introvert you're you need
energy you know you get energy from spending time alone right if you're an extrovert then you get
energy from being with other people so like a lot of people think it's about like oh do you enjoy being
social no that's not it it's where you get your energy from so if you're spending time like alone
needing to reset you know that sort of thing after a lot of social interaction then yeah it's probably a
little bit more introverted is at least that's my understanding yeah that's how i understand too yeah
then yeah i'm definitely on the introvert side for sure yeah i think i think for me as well just
looking at automation and organization um having notes notes plus plus in kaido this year super helped
me just being able to take notes directly from replay like with a key binding super helpful um i've
kind of got jx scout and um some ai stuff built built up which is really nice um and that's good i think
my organization on my poc server could be a little bit better it's not very good there but uh it gets the job
done um and then as far as automation goes i mean this last quarter with shift agents like doing their
thing i think i'm going to be like super powered manual hacker in in 26 for sure um using that so
uh just this past like case study that i did uh just like blew my mind and it's going to completely
change the way i hack i think um you got to remember to do it that's the thing that's what i needed to do
that's what's yeah yeah well i've got the muscle memory for it now too which is which is good like
i you know just got the key binding set up and like you know uh like i know what kind of stuff
shift can handle versus stuff i need to do myself and i know how to give shift to the tools it needs
to be able to like reproduce the things that i wanted to reproduce so a lot of the volume goes to
shift now and and i get to focus a little bit more on the anomalous stuff yeah it does raise the question
and i just thought about this speaking to you guys as like we sort of grow and progress and as the
community levels up as hackers is is automation simply going to be a new name for remembering to
like capture that context in a prompt is that just going to be automation to an extent moving on because
like i don't like the way justin said it i like the way he said uh uh ai powered manual hacker because
i think that's more of what he's doing and i think that that's like where it's going to
be a little bit more of what he's doing and i think that's a little bit more of what he's doing and
i think that's a little bit more of what he's doing and i think that's a little bit more of what he's doing
i think like justin's big finding was because he pointed out a specific thing right he knew
on this sub domain this thing is a little bit unique compared to the rest of the scope that i
normally hack on and he even told it what type of bug class to look for on that on that cookie name
right and so i think like that type of him using his expertise to know where to look and then given
the ad the ability to try lots of things which would save him so much time is really why those types of things worked out for justin so i think uh
so i think um no i think when i think automation brandon i still think of like stuff running over on my bps
right i would say i would say what justin labeled there is what i would call like you know ai powered
manual hacking or whatever yeah so for the for the sake of this conversation would you say that comes
under organization and set like where like what i'm trying to find a mental model where i think it's all
automation it's all automation it's still automation yeah it's a automation ai out of it
no uh it's definitely still automation guys like a computer's doing the work like yeah it's like
manual automation rather than full-scale automation or something yeah but i mean you would still consider
like you know if you had like 403 bypass or something like that that that's automation it's still the same thing you know like
like like i mean is is freaking fuff anime or you know uh automation like of course yeah it's automation
so what's the difference between shift i mean it's using an llm they're all just you know matrix multipliers
it's it's all it's all automation but the the the um you know the there is definitely a difference
between hard code and ai stuff i mean if we want to differentiate there and i think like you said there's two
main boosts that ai bring brings allowing us to create better hard code right and then also being
able to use the ai to actually do the hacking itself so yeah um all right good stuff let's let's look
at these next couple metrics um how much time can you put into bug or can you put into bug bounty where's
your motivation at uh actually we'll stick with those two uh first so like uh for me personally i probably
only have like 20 25 hours a week of of effort and time i can put into you know bug bounty on average
probably maybe closer to 25 um but not a ton of time right now with with other ventures that i want
to be doing the lifestyle that i want to live you know spending time with my wife and kids um you know
boundaries on my work life um yeah i i think that we're just personally you know in the familial
um environment right now we're we're trying to do some things that take time and are challenging
um with uh parts of our family and i think that's going to come first and then you know obviously i've
got hardcore commitments to like kaido and and ctbb and then you know bug bounty is going to be a massive
uh part as well but it's probably only going to look like 25 hours or so yeah before i'll go next
just because it's a hard ditto i mean i'm in the same situation as you right yeah yeah we got kids
busy doing advisor stuff almost exactly the same right 20 25 uh hours i think um and honestly i just
wonder if that's like a hard max for me like i think um it was kind of you know maybe slightly less but
that's what i was doing when i was full-time or whenever i was like working full-time somewhere else
and i also find myself when i tried to do more than that feeling like a little burned out or just
like you know mindlessly watching youtube videos so i think that like that is like um such a sweet spot
for me personally in that amount of hours yeah yeah i would and i've done some reflection on this at the start of this month
mine i couldn't even give you an average it's so all over the place like really all over the place
and then i got into the into the questioning of do i need to be more disciplined around what i'm doing
but then i had a counter argument with myself that this is the bug bounty lifestyle you can do what you
want what's your actual goals so basically i was arguing myself i must have looked crazy if you drove past
me but yeah i don't know i don't know i don't know how many hours unfortunately i really have thought about
this but i even asked my partner as well it just bounces so much depending on if there's events
i think there are weeks i put in 60 hours you know you know i don't think it goes over 60 probably
um 60 hours is more than people think like you know i had to actually work 60 hour weeks whenever i was
in a previous job a few years ago and it's it's a lot more than you think yeah yeah i think there are days
during the life hacking events when i'm really really really going ham and the family stuff is
going okay you know uh where i can put in 60 you know probably 10 it would probably be six tens you
know yeah um but very rare you know and then the rest of the time it's it's much lower for me yeah i
would i would say when i'm doing those longer stints i'm starting to get all sorts of weird problems
now that i never used to get when i was younger like my eyes literally cannot focus
if i do over 10 hours like i come out and i'm partially blind a little bit so i'm a little bit
more conscious of things like that um but yeah i i agree yeah well i do these right fire since we're
running a little yeah get through a bunch that's true um yeah i guess give me a quick metric on y'all's
motivation levels right now like obviously you guys both had some sick years you know how are you guys
you got your motivations going up right now uh what do you where you at brandon yeah yeah it's
definitely on the up i mean when i sat down last week and looked at some of my stats and spoke to rezo
and um monkey briefly about some of these things i was like you know what all in all this has been
fantastic and i found that doing stuff outside of bug bounty but i like hacking security adjacent
definitely fill up another bucket which fuels this bucket so i'm i'm i'm gonna tap into that more but
yeah man i just wanna i just wanna pine some stuff yeah yeah i mean same i just like i'm extremely
grateful for this year every time i think about it i try to rest in that gratefulness because it's so
easy to run past it as like highly ambitious people it's so hard to just like you know be content uh and
so i think i feel that exact way right it's like one i the the good stuff that has happened this year
has driven me to do even more of it and then also just being ambitious i'm like oh i need to do more
i want to do more and so yeah i definitely am stoked to do a lot more hacking a lot more ai stuff
a lot more automation like it's hard during this downtime like during breaks like i'm trying to take
these these couple of weeks off i think you are too justin and it's like i'm just itching to be hacking
i'm just itching to be on my computer to like find bugs build stuff do things and that's exactly
where we want to be right you know and that is exactly where we want to be with with you know the
franz episode back in the day one of the things he said that was one of the key drivers for him was
when he's right about to find something right about to pop something he closes the laptop and walks away
and then he why i could never do that he teases himself you know it makes him like you know desire to
come back you know with more passion and energy and um yeah i think that's i think that's the kind
of energy you got to bring into these breaks like oh man like let's go get it after we after we get back
i will say i freaking love bug bounty it is it is you know super amazing and i'm very passionate very
motivated right now for it for the first time in my life this year i think i found something else
that i love uh and that's product guys i i really like designing products and and i've been getting a little
bit of a taste of this with kaido and and building out shift a little bit and i'm like man i would
really like to be ahead of product somewhere um so i don't know man i like to do it for your own
product you can't just go get hired to be a head of product somewhere no no i i think so i i think i
think i could go either way ahead of product i mean if you if you find a product you really love right
like kaido for example you know it's not my product but it is like you know my baby you know i love it
right um so i would like to be head of product somewhere at some point i don't know if it's
that's something i do this decade or if i do it you know in the future um but i will i will say
in case in case this does a few affect some future timeline you're on justin i will say
as i'm also an advisor for kaido you know disclaimer for everyone seeing how justin is an advisor makes me
think that he would be incredible i had a product like you are way more in the weeds than it makes
any sense from like a financial perspective yeah i don't understand how you care so much i care a lot
i love kind of i use it all the time i love those guys they're my friends i care a lot and somehow
justin cares like five times more he's like asking like intimately deep questions of the kaido team and
like intimately like questions about the product and i just don't even understand how your brain got there
let alone does it make any financial sense given everything that is a part of that decision
and so anyways uh yeah i think that i think that i have seen that passion i guess i should say in the
last few advisor meetings thanks man i appreciate that and i and i really do yeah totally it doesn't
make any sense but i love it and uh and so i'm going to do it anyway um so we'll see we'll see where
that lands but i i love like just working on the user experience and obsessing over the user experience
inside of an app like i think that is super fun um so yeah we'll see we'll see where it goes but i just
wanted to say like i don't think there's anything that i've ever that's really actually made me think
like oh maybe i'd rather do this than than bug bounty and this is the first time like that thought snuck into
my head which is kind of crazy and it because because it does scale a little bit better too right
like bug bounty certainly certainly you know i could build automation make it scale a little bit
better um but bug bounty you know you're doing the work manually and it's work that you love so you
can't complain but it doesn't super scale being head of product and having equity in a startup would
scale so interesting thought there i know we're short on time um i just want to ask um and rezo if you have to drop that's fine too and and brandon and i can close out the episode but um
um what are your overall goals for bug bounty in general like what is why are you doing bug bounty and
and what um yeah what do you want out of it and i'll answer first so you guys have some time to think
but for me i want to find cool volumes and achieve mega impact like i just i love the technical challenge
of it i love the fact that i can say wow i just hacked that company and like now i'm looking at somebody
else's pii like this is crazy um i want to do bug bounty within my my defined work hours i don't want
to let it run over my whole life like it did in the past when i was a younger hacker um i want to
not be consumed by it but let that that distance right like that not being consumed fuel the fire even
more you know um and just have this kind of tug you know relationship with bug bounty um and i want to have
fun with my colleagues right like i want to spend time with other smart people that are going to make
me better as a hacker and i feel like i have a great way of doing that in the bug bounty world
yeah so i would say my goals are you know obviously pretty similar um the first is just like the most
metrics based one is just like keep the current pace of earnings um you know i just don't have another
year like i did this year it's you know it's fantastic i don't feel the need to like massively jack it up or
anything but if i made the same amount this year as i do then or next year as i did this year um i
think that would be incredible um definitely continue to prioritize faith and family and like
you said work within those work hours i you know i have made that a goal this past year and basically
stuck to it it was a part of kind of the you know the deal with my wife with going full-time was
that it would stay between those because it is so easy to be like i could just go make more money
i could just go make more money um and so i think that's cool and then i just want to do cool stuff worth
talking about like you know the i think the mantra for everyone should be do do cool do cool stuff and
tell people about it and that's like the best way to kind of succeed as a human and also not just succeed
like success isn't the end all be all but i think also just have a high level of satisfaction with your
with your work and i think um yeah i think so you know for you obviously it's like finding crazy bugs i
think for me it is too but i think like just do cool stuff this year whether that's you know finding crazy
or building crazy automation that finds cool bugs just like do cool stuff that's worth talking about
brendan yeah for me i feel like i really like the aspect of growing technically and bug bony so like
and i will give some context to the listeners and viewers but when we first started our mentorship justin
client side was like unfathomable for me like it was just like why did why like why how um and i was
very much a servicide guy and not that that didn't treat me like good i found a lot of really cool
servicide bugs there but um the technical aspects of growing bug bounty like only last month that must be
or the month before i started learning mobile hacking and on this i just had my first mobile paid
out as a high yeah which was 4k so let's go that that growing and the the the personal challenge of
growing and think doing things i didn't think i could do before does a lot for me as a person that's
inside a bug bounty but also outside um so that's good and other than that i just maintain
a good level of violence to give me the flexibility to explore other things i also enjoy doing yeah that
makes sense man what what what kind of bug was it in the mobile so it was a bit of a it was a bit of
a funky one um so essentially there's an insecure deep link handler which could allow me to inject
something to then attack an ai i will say no more because it is private but i love it man i love it um
all right so uh rezo i want to be respectful of your time um at the end of this episode we were
going to do our you know call our shot for the next year right with some of these some of these goals
um and we also wanted to do uh predictions for the upcoming year and that sort of thing
so um you need to run down these yeah why don't you try to hit all of these and then if you need to
drop you can and then brandon and i will go back my family's here but i will do this in the next few
minutes and then drop so they'll be fine who would i like to collaborate with i would love to continue
to collaborate with all my good friends so i'm just going to name someone that i haven't collaborated
with that i would love to and that would be matt brown i think it'd be really fun to do something
hardware related i know you and i and him will hopefully pull something off the next year i would
like to continue to spend you know 25 hours per week in general i think that making better use of
my time would be an insane it would be like a really great goal right and i think that that would
be fixed by another answer one of these questions is by having a better anchor program like basically
having something that i'll return to it's like i sit down in the morning check my messages and then i'll
like get to work on that program if i don't have like an h1c or something else going on right and so
yeah i think that what uh what i like to hack on what program or platform i would like to have some
anchor programs and so you know probably will be google plus you know two others or something but
uh i would love to yeah work with you on that like even if you just want to like message me once a
month and be like did you pick one yet you know or make sure you spend time on the anchor program
um as far as hacker motivation i think just the same as this year right just like keep doing cool
stuff and talk to people about it that'll stick money i'd like to earn i already mentioned just the
same amount that i made this year um how many bugs i would like to submit uh i think um yeah i don't
think that this is like a good metric for me i think more it's like hours worked and like time in
because i don't you know if i had submitted 160 like brandon i've been proud of it and if i'd made
as much as i made this year and i had submitted 50 bugs i'd be proud of it so i don't really think
that that like matters much to me i would love to eventually get on the top 100 on hacker one you
know i think being spread out and having bigger bounties um and like a higher impact score is good
but it would be awesome to be on the top 100 for hacker one because like you said being in the top
like you know one or two percent of earners feels amazing and actually is what matters to my family so
numbers are just numbers right they're made up internet points but i would love to be on the
be on the the top 100 page uh severity distribution i don't really care i like finding highs and crits
but it doesn't matter that much to me and oh research i would like to publish some research on
markdown to html impact like uh research specifically from like an ai perspective i've
been working with valentino and bus factor on this and we haven't made anything publishable or even
really that actionable so i think that that would be one thing i would love to do for i want to see that
on the lab man i want to see that on the lab website yeah it needs to be on there i mean yeah
it should be already so anyways that's it good good stuff man did you have any like predictions for
2026 you wanted to shoot out or or you want to leave that to us i do think that 2026 could be the
year of the ai-assisted manual hacker and i think that with the latest shift and shift agent being stable
i think that that is something that is going to be massive this year both for the community and for you
and i um and i don't know if i have any other big predictions i think that you know 2025 was supposed
to be the year of agents and it really was i mean people adopted cloud code and codex in mass and that
was really awesome um so yeah i don't know i yeah i don't think that i have any other like crazy predictions
very good man all right i love you guys merry christmas happy new year everyone it's been an
incredible year and i'm excited to keep doing it so peace thanks for joining us today man bye
um all right brandon um yeah let's kind of work through this same the same thing he had here uh and
kind of go through each one of these ourselves um the first ones are like what are some areas you
would like to grow as a hacker and for me um i would like to be a little bit more reactive when stuff
are is released that i should i could go hack on i i think a lot of times i have my plan and i when
you know some opportunity comes up like either i don't have the flexibility in my life due to like
you know family stuff or other things to go like reactively hack on it um or you know i've just got my
like thing i'm hacking on right now and i'm like i can't be pulled away and and this whole react to shell
thing um kind of slipped by me uh because of the timing with family stuff that was going on but i
would love to be able to react to that and and jump in on those opportunities this year yeah 100 um
so for me i it's interesting because like my next year goals always start in december a little bit
because i i'm pre-planning i the same happened last year i was pre-planning how to message no the year
before i was pre-planning how to message you and all sorts um but for me like mobile hacking i've
recently started doing because i think it's a really nice peripheral scope increaser and like in one of
the most recent events i've done i submitted mobile bugs and outside of that event i've submitted mobile bugs so
peripheral scope is definitely something i want to improve on mobile in that aspect and i've been doing
a load of ai this year i feel like that's something i want to maintain and if i can increase in terms of
throughput definitely a lot of that because yeah it's uh it's west well i mean it's just so nice to hack
it's fun to hack and everyone has something so i don't know man i just i don't find it that fun to hack
to be honest it's getting more fun to hack now you know with these sandboxes that are hooked into
them and all the tools and stuff like that i just like i don't know man i just i like something
i like something a little bit like meatier i feel like and a little bit more deterministic but i i
i agree i mean there is really fun ai scope especially when it integrates more traditional aspects
of computing like file systems or like you know database connections or you know http interaction
something like that um so yeah i i could definitely see that um but that's definitely not my my like
go-to focus for this upcoming year um as far as people the next one on the list here was who would
i like to collaborate with i'm not going to try to list everyone but i have enjoyed these collabs this
year matias franz shubs grep me rezo xss doctor lupin and monkey um and if i left you guys out i'm so
sorry these are just the ones i rattled off my head when i was prepping um but it's been a fun year for
collaborations i think i learned a lot i'm still going to continue doing my solo thing and then collaborate
when it makes sense but um those are kind of the ones that i had in in my list um oh and bus bus of
course yeah of course how could you miss bus man i know dude what am i doing i gotta add i'm gonna put
him in right here no no one's gonna know the the document's gonna reflect it too um yeah um yeah for
me i would say the clients are going pretty much a lot of the people you just listed from the ctb i've
collabed with i have good relationships with we have a lot of fun there's a lot of knowledge transfer there
as well so with those guys i think as well if it comes up i did do a small collab with franz sean jay
mr jonathan bowman and um and those guys in the event if i can collab with them more that would be
great um just such a high level and high caliber of just like militant pwning it is fantastic to see
um ben as well now i'm sick is another guy i like to collab with ads but he yeah ads is where we done
an event together i'm just trying to get all the names up together see here's the thing as well what
i mean about growing as a hacker i didn't do much collaboration at the start because i was still like
very unsure if i could deliver value in a collab and like i was still going through that process of like
coming to terms with bug bounty full-time now i would say next year will probably be a lot more collab
um now i've sort of gone through that journey so that sounds great man i'm excited for that um as far
as uh the next question is how many times per week would i like to hack for me i would like to hack 32
hours a week i probably will try to set a minimum around around 20 and i'll probably hit around 25 again
um but yeah i would love to work on you know bug bounty hunting more it's just stuff gets in the way
um yeah what about you where would you like to how many hours would you like to put into bug bounty ideally
yeah i think and good spot would be five to six hours a day because sometimes i do that because sometimes
i end up actually doing some stuff on the weekend as well if i get nurse sniped and alongside obviously
you yourself have various other projects and income streams that you need to work on um as do i i'm
building them out so i think that would put me in a good spot to give me a little bit of flexibility with
the other ones as well nice that's good i think as far as managing hacker motivation which is the next one
um i think prioritizing other things outside of bug bounty will increase that yearning right like we
talked about for for bug bounty so i think that'll be good um as far as money i would like to earn i'm
going to keep it at the same amount that i did last year i missed i was under my my stretch goal by like
five percent and i might make it this year if if some of the crits that i have right now pay out we'll see
um inside this year but most of the people are off for the rest of the year in the us so i doubt
they'll pay out um but it was it was a it was a fun year for that and i'm going to keep the the that
target at around the same um and i kind of agree with rezo i'm not sure the like number of bugs i
would like to submit is a great metric but i would kind of like to see that go down and the earnings
stay the same or go up right i feel like that would be be kind of um fun to see so around
100 is probably about good for me um but i would like the earnings to either go up or stay the same
um so and then passing that off to you brandon that is hacker motivation how do you plan to manage
that this year um if you would like to say you know ranges or give some rough estimate on how much you
would like to earn and then how many bugs you like to submit yeah hacker motivation i touched upon this
earlier but recognizing now that buckets adjacent to bug bounty um but i still sort of related really
do a lot because i go somewhere i speak about bug bounty some of the bugs i've done some of the cool
stuff i'm doing or i speak to someone that's really interested in bug bounty or runs a security program
or a seesaw of problems and i'm just like ah there it is again just the urge to hack something it just
comes back and strikes so that's a big one for me so i'm definitely going to tap and start going into
the next year how much money would i like to earn so from bug bounty alone i would like to keep that
at the same level that i have done this year with the caveat of increasing my other income streams and
just for everyone listening i pretty much overdone my two goals that i've done i i crushed them both
um in hindsight maybe i set things a little bit too low but my earnings goals got well and
truly beaten the crap out of which is good to say fantastic to say um and bug submit i mean
i'm not even going to comment on this one because i try and adapt to the target very much so if that
means i do a load of volume and not much impact based off of the the decision and constraints i'm in
so be it um i have no problem with that now i'm not precious about it um but yeah that's what i would
say that sounds good all right last couple questions and then we finish the marathon
of uh of the personal hacker inventory um what platforms or programs would you like to hack on what
automation would you like to hack on or like work on what research would you like to do and how would
you like to contribute to the community um for so yeah go ahead so programs i as from my previous
episodes i do have a hit list i keep up to date a hit list of targets that i'd like to hit and that's
very much still under under works what i would say is the notable one that will be a next year target is
google for sure it has to be i have to do it now i'm getting um i don't get fomo often but i'm getting
fomo with google so i'm gonna hit that with automation i'm going to continue building out some
of my frameworks i've done you will have access to one of them soon and very soon um to trial out
and also carrying on the vibe coding and i will say as well codifying my knowledge into prompts a little
bit more to do more things with shift i'm going to put that under automation because i it is in a
sense automation that you need to sort of crack totally um i think for me the platforms and programs
i would like to hack on i'm pretty pretty pleased with what i've got with um you know capital one epic
google and some amazon um i would like to try t-mobile this year i've heard a lot of people having
success on t-mobile so that one could be kind of interesting um i am us-based so that i can go like
you know get one from the store and like set it up pretty easily which is good um so i think i might try that
um automation is going to be largely shift agents for me this year i think and i'm not sure i'm going
to do much else from an automation perspective i don't plan to go back into the recon game i was
thinking about it but i think probably not um as far as research goes i really enjoyed that new relic
thing like that was really fun and i think i will try to do more client-side research if i'm going to do
research um and then as far as contributing to the community i think i'm just going to keep on doing
the podcast man the podcast is like you know i think about all i can manage from a contribution
perspective to the community and i'm going to keep obviously working with kaido releasing plugins
crafting that product to serve the community in that way um and i think that's about all i've got on the
docket i think that'll keep me plenty busy for 2026. oh yeah man absolutely absolutely i think research
wise it will be bug bounty-ish for me what i would want to do is release some research under my company
however because that's a very good it's a double hitter it's research i get to perform and do and
it's also marketing material which i get to represent under my company for some certain things i've got
some things in the notepad when i'm off i'm gonna i'm gonna bounce and bounce some ideas around and see
what i come up with yeah the other thing i would like to do is i would like to do another enterprise app
um like zero day search really quickly i was talking to somebody in the ctbb community about
like that whole grafana thing i did back in 2020 and i had a lot of fun with that so i might do that
again i might just pick like a high target you know like often found across the bug bounty scope
um you know enterprise app grab the source code reverse it try to find a unauthenticated zero day
i think that'd be pretty fun just just like a fun thing um as far as predictions for the upcoming year goes
um i think that i i agree with with um rezo that shift agents and you know hacker supplemented
or yeah ai supplementing manual hacking is going to be a necessity by the end of 26 i think um and
shift is going to need to grow a little bit as a product i think but before then um but i think it's
90 of the way there right now and and uh i've already had really good success with it i plan to continue
using it um i think source code review is going to change a lot too um client-side source code review with
you know cloud code or gemini or whatever it is uh i think will will really be super helpful this year
um yeah besides that i i don't really have any other massive massive predictions i think the bounties
will continue to go up uh overall i think um bug bounty isn't going anywhere um do you have any thoughts
for predictions for the next year yeah i feel so i was listening to a podcast about how
cloudflare have now entered the browser game a little bit and how the fundamentally all cloudflare
customers are turning off access to ai crawlers and they're monetizing it um where content creators
get paid for their content in another way and how they've open sourced this agent to agent like payment
system um i think that as we progress and we sort of hit that critical mass now a little bit with some of
these targets that we're hacking we are going to start to see a bit more of this third-party attack
surface that we haven't really had to see before whether that comes in new protocols like that new
mcp servers and new like ai related integrations so if that's your flavor of hacking and you enjoy hacking
stuff like that keep an eye out for it so i would expect to see more things like that coming up but like
i don't want to keep like saying oh yeah i agree with what he said but i actually do agree with what
you and reza said about in terms of like the hacker behavior i would say i'm very much in the same
bobon yeah yeah i think that's i think that's a no-brainer i think we will start seeing you know we
already saw expo kind of do their run this year but i think i would also predict that probably this year
we will see you know a like bug bounty hunter created autonomous you know ai hackbot essentially
start really really really getting some crazy results we've seen that a little bit already
actually um some of the niche members of the ctvv community have shared some success with hack bots
they've created but i think we'll see something really really start to climb the leaderboard in a
meaningful way this year um yeah and i i think the other prediction that comes to mind is that i think
it will actually get harder than it already is to compete in the recon games because with the with
the the presence of vibe coding you know changing who can create automation i think that we will see
more competition even than we have in the past there so um the people that are winning in that
arena will be the people with access to custom bugs right you know bugs that other people aren't looking
for so it's going to become a lot more of a research game and um and you know one of the things we
have done a little bit with ctvv is try to you know encourage pairings between recon hackers and
you know researchers um and i think that would be another really fun thing to push this year
in the ctvv community is like okay let's try to get let's spend a couple weeks trying to find you know
cloud misconfigurations you know uh enterprise software misconfigurations something that is like
not a zero day but is like a common misconfiguration that we can hand to the recon guys and get like you
know a split on um to generate passive income moving forward um yeah i think that yeah i think because i
think the recon part of that though is going to become a lot less valuable because more people
are going to be able to do it because of the the vibe coding so it i think splits for recon boys will
probably be forced down from a market perspective um due to more supply in the market agreed yeah it's
very unlike you only have to go into the ctv channel and like it feels like the amount of tools and tips and
like all these little things that have been vibe coded extensions burp extensions they're all just coming
out so much quicker totally like it's it's reducing friction on mic flow so yeah i'd agree i'd agree with that
very nice all right man that was a marathon episode my voice is about to give way i was just like
coughing a lung out on mute while while you're answering that last question but um that is a wrap
on 2025 uh in critical thinking thank you guys so much for listening this year it's been amazing our
viewership has been very supportive we brought on brandon as a co-host um we'll see you guys in 2026
see you in 2026 and that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking thanks so much for watching to
the end y'all if you want more critical thinking content uh or if you want to support the show head
over to ctvb.show discord you can hop in the community there's lots of great high-level hacking
discussion happening there on top of master classes hack alongs exclusive content and a full-time hunters
guild if you're a full-time hunter it's a great time trust me all right i'll see you there
it's hard not to just keep talking about stuff but it's like oh it's off the air gotta wait i'm like
have you seen the meme of the guy when he has the veins popping out of his head yes that's exactly how i feel right now